hi i'm a big fan what was the point of
the evolutionary process to have an
appendix why is it not an essential
organ anymore
and i wanted to pose this question
because uh
it is it is something that we have
addressed directly in
our in the first of our health and
medicine chapters in the book that we
are writing that will be out next year
so i don't know if we want to say
anything more than that right now
well i do want to say at least one thing
okay um which is
it was obvious that the story that the
appendix
was a vestigial organ of no value
was wrong right what the appendix does
is a more interesting question than that
but anyway years ago i generated a
test to counteract the argument that in
order to establish that something was a
product of adaptation
you needed to demonstrate that there was
genetic variability and that the genes
that encode the thing
uh outcompete genes that don't this is
nonsense logically speaking
if a trait is complex
if it is expensive and if it persists
over evolutionary time
it is telling you that it is doing
something positive
for the creature and the appendix always
passed this test so i always wondered
about this
um in more recent times it has become
clear what exactly the appendix does but
the
the important part of the story there is
a leading hypothesis
that it's you know it's not wholly
demonstrated so i don't know i don't
know that i would say this
i'm not so sure about that i believe it
has been demonstrated maybe not
sufficiently that it
rules out the possibility of another
interpretation but it has withstood
substantial test i would say um
and what what i think is most important
to realize though
is that a story that never made any
sense
and didn't match the uh
the ancestral data floated for years
on the basis that people could remember
it and it seemed
uh you know logical enough to people who
weren't very good at thinking
evolutionarily
and that that is a cautionary tale
because you know you can make the same
argument
for example for religion that this is a
massively expensive
uh phenomenon that persists over
evolutionary time and has a lot of
complexity to it
and people are still telling us that
it's a mind virus and other such
things so the belief that something is
uh expensive and persistent and not
noticed by evolution even though there's
an obvious way
to save um should attract our attention
and in the case of the appendix
it's not even just the expense of the
organ which is presumably small
not negligible but small but the cost of
having one
right i know numerous people
in my direct sphere who have
had an appendicitis and presumably most
or all of them
would have died from appendicitis if not
for
medical intervention and what that says
is that the fitness cost of having such
a an organ is potentially very large
but here's here's the teaser so we're
not gonna we're not gonna go into the
whole story right now the teaser is
uh you know consider what about
so the appendix is part of our gi tract
our gastrointestinal tract so
consider in our gi tract is what takes
in our
our food and converts it into nutrients
that we can use
and allows us to get rid of the parts
that we can't use
so what looking at our diet would be an
interesting a good place to start to
figure out
um how have our diets changed obviously
dramatically
from those of our even just
pre-industrial ancestors
that question is relevant especially in
light of the finding which probably many
people don't know
which is that the rate of appendicitis
is incredibly high among post-industrial
people that much we do know
brett just mentioned that he's known
several people with extreme bouts of
appendicitis including your dad um
yes yes um
but uh
yeah i suppose that's true um but what
is
what is true what is more interesting is
that pre-industrial people have almost
no rates of appendicitis
so it is this is something that has
changed
in the industrialization of our food
almost certainly and in fact what you
know the leading hypothesis for uh what
it has that
has changed and therefore what the
function the appendix is
is consistent with this understanding uh
that this is about hyper novelty
of the very modern human condition that
has uh
turned an organ that actually was quite
important
into one that is apparently more of a
hazard than a benefit
so it has increased the hazard and
other features of the modern environment
have reduced the value
to near zero for modern people so are we
sure we don't want to
no we can do it okay i thought you
didn't want to so um let's just say
the leading hypothesis is that the
appendix
preserves a an isolate of the community
of microorganisms in your gut
that aid in the extraction of nutrients
from food
and that this process means that when
you
are infected by some competing uh
microorganism and you're you have uh
chemical warfare going on biological
warfare going on in your gut
and you potentially lose your
gut flora to diarrhea then
this isolate that is basically in a
little pouch that sticks off of your
intestine
this isolate can then repopulate your
gut very quickly
with gut flora for which you are well
adapted
so that you can immediately go back to
extracting the nutrients from food
in a very efficient way it's your body's
probiotic source
yeah it's your body's probiotic source
maintained right where it needs to be
in a condition where it can be
preserved through a gastrointestinal
infection and i would just last thing is
the reason that you can eliminate it and
apparently suffer no harm
is that you have so much extra food you
don't need to be efficient at extracting
resources now it may be bad for you
what you are repopulated with may not be
uh very good for you in terms of the
community of microorganisms and you may
suffer all sorts of
gastrointestinal problems that put you
on things like proton pump inhibitors
that increase your risk of covid for
instance just to go back
to that for example for example but
there's also in the modern environment
no guarantee
that your current while you're healthy
gut flora are the right ones for you
either hence these fecal transplants
that people
have so so two just two two more things
on this i mean there's this goes in a
lot of different interesting directions
but
um one of the other predictions of of
what you just said
is that whereas uh pre-industrial people
who are still alive today don't tend to
have um appendicitis at
all um another prediction of the model
that brett just laid out is that they
will have much higher rates of of
diarrhea
of incidence of diarrhea um that you
know are common enough that they don't
really
think about it that much whereas you
know it's rare enough for
sort of weird you know western educated
industrialized rich democratic
uh country inhabitants uh to have that
they can go like oh yeah that was like
six months ago it was kind of ugly right
um whereas um pre-industrial people tend
to have it more often and the idea there
is that the repopulation of the
effectively probiotic
gut bacteria would be a more of a
regular and necessary part
of a functional gi tract for such people
who are regularly
losing all of their good bacteria
through these
to these diary incidents the other thing
is that the appendix is not just in
humans
across mammals there's a very sort of it
looks almost chaotic
if you just map the distribution of
appendix and also the cecum which is
another out pouching of the
digestive tract onto the mammalian tree
it should it's
it's it's popping on and popping off
like evolving and then
disappearing lots and lots of times um
but
it it tracks interestingly with diet
and so this is again um sort of
supporting evidence that this is about
um changes in diet that have rendered
this thing
um not um not only not useful but
actually a hazard
yes and um the
explanation that it was vestigial the
wrong explanation which we should have
spotted from the very beginning and some
of us did i mean i always knew the
appendix was going to turn out to be
useful but um
the uh the wrong explanation was that it
was a cecum
that was being eliminated by selection
over time
now cecum is a mechanism for
digesting cellulose it's basically a
pouch that
allows so no mammal can digest cellulose
but you can have microorganisms that do
the digesting for you in fact i think no
complex animal can digest cellulose
even termites have microorganisms i
think that's right that allow them to do
it yeah and so the point is you need a
place
being wood um so you need a place
for the microorganisms that can digest
cellulose so this is so interesting
cellulose is actually
the mirror image of a molecule that we
actually very easily digest but we don't
have an enzyme that deals
with the flip side and it's apparently
very what's what's the mirror image
it's uh it's um here no it's a stark
um and so those are those are cis trans
versions of
in order to digest the cellulose you
need
microorganisms that have an evolutionary
history that allows them to digest
cellulose
you need a place for those creatures to
live so even termites have a place for
those
creatures to live in their gut and that
thing in mammals is a cecum
but the explanation that our appendix
is a cecum that is vestigial and
therefore receding and disappearing over
time
doesn't make any sense because we don't
have the evidence for
an ancestor that digested cellulose and
needed a cecum
and so the point is you know
superficially it makes sense but not
that map that hypothesis onto a
phylogenetic tree of our closest
relatives
and falsified like that's all you have
to do it's just it's just not a match
for our evolutionary history yep
you